hello everyone and welcome to this
interesting video tutorial on formula
one data analysis using python
in this video we'll be using four
publicly available data sets about
formula one that has information from
1950 to the 2019 f1 season
we'll see how using the python libraries
you can perform explority data analysis
and draw valuable insights
so let's begin by understanding what
formula one is
formula one also known as f1 is a
motorsport defined by open wheeled
single sheet race cars
it features the best drivers in the most
powerful and technically advanced cars
the sport is governed by the fia that is
international automobile federation
here 10 teams comprising of two drivers
each compete in a series of races over a
period of one year to find out the
ultimate driver and a constructor
champion
in our demonstration we'll be using four
data sets let me show them one by one
these are all csv files
now this is the first data set that
we'll be using in our demo
so if you notice the data set does not
have column
names in fact none of the data sets have
column names so while importing the data
set we will assign the column names
using the names parameter i'll show that
in a
while
now this is the results data set
the results data set has information
about
the result id
then we have the race id driver id
we have
the constructor id
grid position
then we also have information about the
fastest
lap then we also have information about
rank
the fastest lap speed
and the status id
now moving on to the second data set
which is about
racers
now this is the second data set which is
about races so
it has information about the race id
the year in which the race was held then
we have
the round number circuit id
then the name of the
grand prix so you can see here
australian malaysian chinese spanish
monaco turkish british german
and others
then we have the
date on which the gp was held or the
grand prix was
held
we have the time
and a url which basically leads to the
wikipedia page of that particular
grand prix for that year
now moving on to our third data set
so this is our third data set which is
about drivers
now it has the driver id the name of the
driver you can see here hamilton
rossberg alonso
reichen
then we have sato
masa
button weber and all
after that we have the
number code
then we have the
phone name of the driver the surname of
the driver
and then we have the date of birth of
that particular driver we have the
nationality as well
we have the wikipedia page
for the
driver
now moving on to the last data set which
is about
constructors
so this is the fourth and the final data
set that we'll be using in our data
analysis project so here we have the
constructor id
then the constructor reference
in formula one
and this is the actual name of the
constructor so we have mclaren
we have
bmw sauber williams then we have ferrari
toyota red bull force india
we also have jordan jaguar and all
next we have the
nationality and the url
that is the wikipedia page of
that particular constructor
now let's head over to our jupiter
notebook and we'll start with our
analysis
here is my jupyter notebook that i'll be
using for this demo you can see some of
the cells are already filled this is
just to make sure we save some time
so using these data sets that we just
saw and our libraries such as numpy
pandas matplotlib and cbon
we'll answer specific questions such as
the drivers and constructors who have
been the
most successful throughout the history
of f1 sport
then we'll explore the impact of
starting and finishing positions and if
the speed of the cars has changed over
the years
so let's begin with our analysis
first and foremost we are going to
import all the necessary libraries so
here i am importing numpy pandas
matplotlib and cbon
and after that i am writing percentage
matplotlib inline that is to ensure that
all the plots are embedded in line i'll
hit shift enter to run it
take some time there you go so we have
successfully imported all the libraries
now the next step is to
load the data and assign
column names
so
i load my
first data which is results i'll say pd
dot
read underscore
csv
i'll give my
file name which is results dot
csv
and then using the
names parameter
i'll pass in the
column names so actually i have written
the column names in a notepad let me
open that
so i have this f1
notepad created which has the column
names i'll just start copying
the column names
within the names parameter i'll paste it
if i scroll to the right you can see the
different column names that
have been assigned
and
that
i'm going to say
comma and i'll write
header equal to
none
i'll close the bracket
cool
similarly let's
import the second data set which is
about
races i'll say
pd dot
read underscore csv
i'll give my
file name which is racist.csv
and then
i'll give the
names parameter this is actually names
and not name
okay
i'm going to
copy the
second line
and i'll paste it here
and again
i'll say
header
equal to
none
next
we'll import our third data set which is
about
drivers
so i'll say pd dot read underscore csv
i'll say
drivers dot csv
then
again use the
names parameter
and i'll copy the
third line now which has the column
names for the
drivers data set
here
i
need to give
another parameter which is header
equal to
none
finally we are going to import our
constructors data set
it's a constructors equal to pd dot
read underscore csv which is the
function present in the pandas library
i'll say
constructors.csv which is my file name
and then again i'll use the names
parameter
i'll go to my notepad and this time i'll
copy the
fourth line which has the column names
for the constructors dataset
i'll paste it
and
here i'll give my
final parameter that is header equal to
none
all right
now
let me hit shift enter to
run it
okay we see some error here let's debug
the error it says
no such file or directory drivers dot
csv
let's see
where was the issue
this should be
driver.csv
cool now we have successfully loaded the
data and assigned the columns to the
various data sets
now the
next
analysis
is to merge all the data set
so here i'll create a data frame called
df and i'll use
pd dot
merge function
first i'll use the
results data frame that we just
imported above this one
and
i'm going to
merge it with
racist data frame
and from the resist data frame i am
going to take
specific columns like the
race id
then
i need the
year
after that i need
name
next
i'm going to take
the round column as well
and
i'm going to use
on parameter so
on parameter
is actually
the column that is common to both the
data frames that is results and races so
here my common column
is going to be the race id because it is
present in both the data sets
and i would like to merge
so for that i am going to use how so i
am going to use a left join
so
if you know sql you will be aware of
left join it takes all the rows from the
left table and only the matching rows
from the right table
again going to use the merge function so
i'll write
df equal to pd dot
merge
i'll say
df comma and now i'm going to
merge the
ivor's data set
and
i'm going to select
specific columns so i'll say driver id
make sure there are no spelling mistakes
in the
column names
then i'll say
driver
ref which is the name of the driver or
reference
comma
and then i want the
nationality of the
driver
all right
we'll give a comma i'll say on
which column i want to merge so here the
common column
is going to be the driver id
again
how is going to be a left join
into the final
merge part i'll say again df equal to pd
dot
merge
i'll pass in my data frame and my final
data set which i have is about
constructors
from constructors we are going to choose
specific columns so i'll take the
constructor
id
then i'll take
the name column
and again the
nationality column of the
manufacturer
okay
here i'll say
on
equal to
the common column i'll use this
constructor id
you give a comma and say how
equal to
left again
make sure
you're merging it with the
right column names so let's run this
cell to merge
all the four data sets
i'll hit
enter oops there is some error let's see
it says constructor
id index
okay there's a spelling mistake this
should be
constructor id cool
let's run it
there you go
now
the next thing we want to do is to drop
the unnecessary columns
so i'll say df dot
drop
within the drop function
we are going to pass in the
column names i'll say
number
then we also don't want the
position column
next we have
position underscore
text
after that we have
labs
next we are going to drop
fastest
lap
then we will also drop the
status id
comma
we drop the result underscore id column
then
going to drop the race underscore id
column
we'll also
drop driver underscore id column
and finally we are going to drop
the
constructor underscore id column
and
i'll say access equal to
1
and in place i'll see equal to true
because i want to remove it from my
original data frame that is df
there you go
now the next
thing i want to do is i want to rename
some of the columns so i'll say df dot
rename
i'll say
columns equal to
now we are going to pass in a dictionary
i'm going to change the
rank
to
test
underscore lab underscore rank
let me give a comma
now i'll say
name underscore x
equal to
i'll say the
grand prix name so i'll say gp
underscore name
next column i'm going to focus is
the nationality column so i'll say
nationality underscore
x
i'll give a colon the value i'm going to
pass in is
driver nationality
all right
up next
we have one column called
underscore
y
and that i'm going to change it to
constructor name
another comma
we want to say
nationality
underscore
y
colon
change it to
constructor nationality
underscore nationality
finally we have
driver
underscore ref column
and that i am going to replace with
just
driver
finally i'll say
in place
equal to
true
will
just verify if all the column names are
correct
let's run it
all right so now we have
successfully renamed
the columns
after that
in the next cell i'm going to
rearrange the columns so here i'm
using the same data frame and we have
just renamed the columns so starting
with your
grand pre name round driver
nationality and others
let's run this
up next
we're going to drop the
2019 season data because
it is incomplete so i'll say df equal to
df
then i'll say
here
not
equal to
2090
let's see how to
sort the values so i'll say df equal to
df dot
sort underscore values which is the
function name
i'm going to sort it by
year
followed by
round
followed by
the
position
underscore
order
comma i'll say
ascending
equal to
first let's say is false
next i have true
and then
i'll have true
all right
moving ahead
now we are going to see how to replace
the
put slash
n values in
the time column with something called
nan because the time column was not
registered when a driver did not finish
a race or was lagged by another driver
so to do this i am going to say
df dot
time dot i'm going to use the replace
function
and here i'll say
forward slash or backward slash
n and i'm going to replace with
numpies nan
i'll say
in place equal to true
let me just copy this because we are
going to use the same
emitters
next i am going to replace the
milliseconds value
milliseconds dot
replace i'll paste it here
then i'll say df dot
fastest
underscore
lab underscore
rank dot
replace
paste it
next i have
df dot
fastest dot
lab
dot
time
they replace
to that i have
the next column which is
speed so i'll say fastest
underscore
lap underscore
speed dot
replace
i'll paste it
so here
i'm going to replace
this particular value
the
backward slash
n with
nan
let me run it
cool
step i'm going to
change the data types for
fastest underscore lab underscore speed
to float then fastest underscore lab
underscore rank to float again
now
problem here is we cannot convert it
into an integer because there are
missing values so we are going to change
it to float
again for milliseconds also we are
changing it to float values
let me run it
now
i'll reset the index
let me show you how to reset the index
i'll say df dot
reset
underscore
index
i'll say
drop
equal to true
i'll give a comma and say
in place equal to true
all right
that we have
done our initial
processing step of the data set
now we'll check the shape of the data
set then we see
all the data sets the
total number of normal values the memory
usage and we'll
check the head of the data set
now to see the total number of
rows and columns i'll say
print
df dot shape
you can see here there are total 24
197 rows in my data set and there are
total of 15 columns
now let's use
df dot
info function
so it gives me the
year the grand prix name
the round number
driver constructor name grid
position order total number of points
time
then time in milliseconds the fastest
lap rank
the fastest lap speed
the nationality of the driver
nationality of the constructor
then here we have the
total number of non-null objects
and then you also have the memory usage
at the bottom
finally let's see the
head of the data frame so i'll say
df dot
head let's say i want to check the first
10 rows
where you go
if i scroll down you can see here we
have the top 10 rows printed
and you have the year the grand prix
name round driver constructor name and
other columns now let me just
brief you about what these column names
stand for
so the year column that you see here is
the season that the grand prix took
place and then we have the
name of the grand prix
now the round column is the number of
the race in each season for example one
means it was the first race of the
season
and then
two means it was the second race of the
season so so on and so forth
then we have the name of the driver
that we have the
name of the car constructor so you can
see ferrari mercedes red bull renault
then we have the grid that is the
starting position before the race
actually this depends on the
qualifications which occur one day
before the race
then we have the position underscore
order column this means the final
position at the end of the race then we
have the points column that is the total
number of points scored in the race
next we have the time that is the amount
of time that took to finish the race
only the winners time is displayed and
drivers behind the winner are shown how
far behind the winner they are
then we have the milliseconds column
that is the amount of time that took to
finish the race in milliseconds
if i just scroll down i'll just move to
the
right
go to the top
then we have the fastest underscore lab
underscore rank that is the order of the
fastest lab during race
next we have
fastest lap time that is the shortest
amount of time that took to complete a
lap in the release
then we have the lap speed that is the
average speed of the
fastest lap
then we have the
country to which the driver belongs to
and then we have the
constructor nationality that is the
country where the car constructor is
based out of
okay
now
here i am going to set my figure size to
10 comma 6 this is going to be for all
the
plots that we are going to create
afterwards
cool
we'll create a data frame that will have
all the grand prix winners
so here i'm going to say
driver
underscore
winner equal to
use my data frame
df dot i'll say loc
then i'll say
df
i want
the position underscore
order
and that should be equal to 1 so which
means
the driver
1 degrees
and then
i am going to
use the
group by function
i'm going to group it by
driver
and
for values i'll say
position underscore
order
use the
count function
followed by
sort underscore
values
i'll say
ascending equal to
false
we change it to
to underscore
frame
dot
reset underscore
index
what essentially i'm doing here is i am
finding out
all the drivers that have participated
and
won a grand prix
next
i'm going to create a
bar plot so this is going to be the
first visualization of our analysis
so i'll say
sb
which we have taken in our
analysis ideally it should be sns but sb
also will work
so i'll say sb
dot
bar plot
i'm going to say data equal to
driver underscore
winner
the y-axis i'll have
driver
in the x-axis i'll have
position
underscore
order
then i have
color equal to
green
that i'll set my
alpha value
to
0.5
or let's say
0.8
then
we are going to
give a title to our plot so i'll say plt
dot
title
let's say most
grand prix
winners in f1
then we are going to label our access so
for y label i will have
driver
name
we have
the x label
that will have
number of
grand prix wins
and i'll say
plt dot
y
text
let's run it
and you can see we have our first
bar plot here now the bar plot
shows that there are
a large distribution of
grand prix wins
only a few drivers in history of f1 have
won over 20 grand prairie in their
careers and there are some drivers who
completely dominated the f1 racing and
have won over
50 grand priest in their careers so we
are going to focus on those
top five or top 10
drivers
in the next section so what i am doing
here is
from the
above
result that we just got i'm going to
filter out only the
top 10 so i'm going to use the head
function
and
inside that i passed in 10 if i print it
you can see here
as per the data that we have
we have michael schumacher who
is the position
order leader with
gp events then we have hamilton vettel
frost senna alonso
then we have stevert clerk and lauda
the data that we have is
not the most recent one so if you check
the actual stats hamilton has actually
overtaken michael sumacre and has
won over
103 close to 103 races as of now
and
next we have michaelson macker so this
is not the most recent data
cool
now using this data we'll create another
bar plot for the top 10
drivers so i'll say sb dot
bar plot
i'll say data equal to
the
name that we have used that is top 10
drivers so i'll say top 10
drivers
in the y axis we'll have
the
driver name in the x-axis we'll have
position
underscore
order
for the bars i'm going to use a color
equal to
let's say blue this time
i'll set my alpha value
to be
0.8
and
i'll say let's say
line
width
equal to
0.8
and i'll also give
an edge color of let's say
black
follow the same drill i'm going to give
a title to my plot so i'll say plt dot
title
most
gp
winners in a phone
give a y label
that says
driver
name
and then i'll have x label which will
have
number of
on pre
bins
cool
let me see if everything is fine
and then we'll
run this there you go
you can see we have a very nice
horizontal
bar plot that shows the
top drivers in f1 so as per our data
that we have we have michael schumacher
who has won over 91 or close to
91
races then we have hamilton vettel
alonso
all right
in the same way we are going to create
bar plot for the top constructors that
have participated in f1
so here i'm finding out
all the
constructor winners so here
i'm using my position underscore order
equal to equal to 1 and then i'm using
the group by
based on the constructor name
and then i'm finding the count of
position order and sorting the values
in
descending order and i'm changing it to
frame or to a data frame
and to create my bar plot i'm using the
bar plot function the data which is
constructor underscore winner
in the y-axis i'll have the constructor
name on the x-axis i'll have the
position order
so
you can see here i've used color as pink
and i've given a title x label by label
and vertex
let's run it
there you go so here you can see again
the data is
widely
spread
so we have a lot of constructor names
now
our next task is to
check the
top 10 gpa constructor windows so here
i'm using the head function and finding
out the top 10
if i run it
you can see here
the manufacturing companies or the
constructors who have won the most
number of
races
are ferrari
mclaren
williams then we have mercedes
red bull tim lotus renault
and others
okay
now we'll convert this data into a
horizontal
bar graph or a bar chart
so that will show the bar plot for the
top 10
constructors
now let me show you how to do it
so i'll say
sb which is for c bond dot
bar plot
i'm going to say data equal to
top 10 let me just confirm
the name we have top 10 constructors
scroll down i'll say constructors
y-axis i'll have
constructor
on the x-axis i'll have
position underscore order
then
i'll say
color
equal to let's say we'll use the
red color for the bars
then i'll set my alpha to
0.8
i'll say
line width equal to
0.8
and my
edge color i'll say
black
that i'll say plt dot
title
say
top 10
most
gp
wins
lt dot
by label would be
constructor
name
and i'll have plt dot
x label
as
number of
gp
bins
cool
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
ferrari at the top then we have mclaren
williams more cities i'm pretty certain
by
the end of 2021 season mercedes would
have gained a lot of wins since hamilton
has been on the top
for mercedes for quite some time now
all right
now
finally we are going to
create a
regression plot that will
show how
two variables that is the starting
position and finishing
position
vary
so to do that i'm going to exclude the
data points with grid 0 because it skews
the data so 0 means that the driver
started from the
pit lane
so i'm using this function called reg
plot
to plot my
regression line
let me run it and show you the result
there you go
so if you see here
we can easily see there's a linear
relationship between the starting and
finishing position so on the x-axis we
have the starting position on the y-axis
we have the
finishing or the finished place
so which is what is actually expected
right now we can also see that
most races had up to
25 drivers you can see the density of
the points here
but
some of the recess also had over 30
drivers you can see the
light color blue dots
next
we are going to
check whether the speed of the cars
changed over the years since this data
is only available from 2004 onwards so
we have
we have taken
years that start from 2004 onwards
now let me show you the result
of this data
so essentially we are plotting the
average speed among
all teams during the fastest lap at
individual grand prix and here on the
y axis you have the average fastest
speed in kilometer per hour and then you
have the different
gps
and
you can see here the year values
now
in general what we see is there's a
decrease in the average fastest lap from
2004
till around
2015
for almost all these circuits
and again from 2015 onward the speed
started
to increase
you can see here there's an increase
after 2015 there's an increase there's
an increase here as well
you can also notice that
the speed is very different on each
track for instance if you check the
italian grand prix which is here
italian gp has the
fastest race in the calendar with
average speed exceeding over
240 kilometers per hour on the other
hand if you
talk about the
monaco grand prix let me show you if you
see here
the monaco gp is the slowest race with
average speed below
160 kilometer per hour now this is
actually expected because the monaco
grand prix
has very narrow streets and hence the
drivers cannot
drive fast in this circuit
all right
so
that brings us to the end of our
explorative data analysis on the formula
one datasets
i hope it was useful and informative
if you have any queries please feel free
to put them in the comments section of
the video thanks again stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here